das am weitesten entfernte objekt dass
menschen je untersucht haben ist noch
ungewöhnlicher als wir berichtet hatten
erste bilder sparen ja für ein
schneemann ähnliches objekt aus zwei
verschieden großen teilen
doch es ist ganz anders und es gibt der
wissenschaft jetzt rätsel auf tricks um
science-fiction hier gibt es täglich
faszinierendes 1 videos abonniert den
kanal nur dank verpasste nicht herzlich
willkommen wir hatten ja darüber
berichtet der asteroid ultima thule ist
64 milliarden kilometer entfernt und
zieht im kuipergürtel dem
asteroidengürtel rund um unsere
sonnensystem seine bahn noch nie wurde
ein objekt von einer sonde untersucht
das so weit entfernt ist das alleine ist
schon der wahnsinn zur erinnerung beim
vorbeiziehen an stern machte das objekt
etwas sehr seltsames es ist rund 30
kilometer lang und hat eine sehr
seltsame form das wurde 2017 und 2018
festgestellt mit zahlreichen teleskopen
wurde dabei die flugbahn von ultima
thule beobachtet oder wie die korrekte
bezeichnung ist 2014
69 der hass ist allerdings so weit von
der sonne entfernt dass er kein licht
reflektiert oder nur ganz ganz wenig
allerdings verdeckt er immer wieder
sterne und dabei wurde festgestellt dass
sie nicht einfach hell und wieder dunkel
werden sondern abgedunkelt werden dann
wieder etwas heller da werden dann
wieder etwas dunkler und dann erst
wieder endgültig hält ultima thule muss
also eine sehr seltsame form haben und
die damals vermutete form ja sie ist
noch seltsamer wie jetzt bestätigt wurde
es besteht nicht nur aus zwei exakten
kugeln wie zunächst vermutet sondern
dieses objekt ist noch verrückter das
war schwierig festzustellen denn ultima
thule dreht sich sehr speziell und
rotiert wie ein propeller zeigt uns also
immer dieselbe seite und so ist die
reflektionen immer gleich jetzt hat die
nasa aber beim vorbeiflug einen blick
von hinten gegen das sonnenlicht
erhascht und dieser blick zeigt ein noch
seltsames objekt ultima thule besteht
nämlich nicht aus zwei kugeln sondern
aus einer zerbeult muss so sieht
jedenfalls dass kleinere teil aus und
aus einem pfannkuchen das größere objekt
ist nämlich ziemlich flach zwar ist in
dem kurzen nasa video nur die eine seite
beleuchtet aber durch die abdeckung von
sternen konnte das forschungsteam
ermitteln dass der große teil von uns
matula extrem flach ist jetzt hat die
nasa also die neu ermittelte form
veröffentlicht und jetzt gibt es mehr
fragen als antworten die
wissenschaftlerinnen und wissenschaftler
können sich nicht erklären wie ein
solches objekt entstehen konnte
eigentlich müsste es für runder sein
wir haben noch nichts vergleichbares
gesehen dass die sonne umkreist das sagt
ellen stern chef wissenschaftler des
teams der new horizons sonde die die
bilder gemacht hat jetzt wird also erst
mal überlegt was das objekt so geformt
haben könnte wenn es neue erkenntnisse
dazu gibt erfahrt ihr es natürlich hier
also abonnieren dich vergessen geht es
weiter mit unsichtbar durch zeit löcher
geht das bei neugier zone richtig cooles
video draufklicken anschauen und
unbedingt abonnieren ansonsten bis dann
bleibt dran